[Musique]
tous moi je chantais déjà mais alors
s'occupe du développement de l'édition
numérique passé où j'ai toujours
l'impression dans le monde de l'édition
numérique c'est un peu vu comme le
diable vous êtes là pour bousculer un
peu les habitudes jusqu'au bas ça c'est
à vous de me le dire j'ai eu à la il a
remis dit d'accord pour savoir ça va
plus la leur en format contente très en
forme
super pour le manuscrit donc non je
publierai pas d'enjeu temps sec avait
compris ça me ferait plaisir dit mais
invaincu enfin je te dis tu as refusé
mon manuscrit
qu est ce que j -pd ou deux mois qu'est
ce que vous pensez de la polémique qui
fait rage autour de votre livre la
question c'est de savoir si leur mention
de droit de s'inspirer de personnes
existantes et sur canapé lit entre les
lignes je crois que c'est quelque chose
c'est une façon de se venger je n'aime
pas la façon dont tu parles des femmes
et ce qui tient il la traite comme un
objet les ventes s'effondrent c'est
dingue les gens lisent des livres sur
smartphone
moi je dis pas sur tablettes parce que
c'est pas ton époque j'temmerde
je me trompe elana après pourquoi tu dis
ça c'est dans un couple désire c'est pas
le début la femme tous préfèrent vivre
dans les po crazy moins six fois
l'hypocrisie on est marié depuis 20 ans
[Musique]
le
battu par ils sont quelque chose moi
j'ai pas trop envie d'en parler ça
avance bien bien bien
on n'en saura pas plus
[Musique]